for me I love to go hiking and then that
makes me feel like that's sort of my
medicine non-addictive and it's nice for
you if you know you have to mean address
a crowd of people or be somewhere where
you may have to be on a little bit
what do you do to get into that space I
prepare for screenings and press and I
prepare by meditation I practiced yoga I
ride horses I just try to do things that
connect me to myself you know and I find
I also hike and just anything in nature
just to ground me I just want to be able
to stay present and grounded with
everything that I do and that takes a
lot of rejuvenation time needed in
between those those things in terms of
rejuvenation I mean so much of
filmmaking or acting is generating your
own opportunities so that creates a lot
of times very little downtime and what
do you do when you feel tired or down
and you just really have to push
yourself remember what if you're not
able to be in a place where you can
meditate murder in a public space
you have to just keep going you have a
mantra that you save yourself um I
really when I just am so exhausted and
I've been working like 14 hour days I
think the way that I keep going is I
just keep thinking about the people that
I want to reach and that I want to help
and and telling myself that there's
always someone that has it so much worse
than me and the fact that i'm getting to
live my dream rejuvenates me every time
no matter how tired I am I can still go
and it's always focusing on I am able to
live my dream and I've got to get this
everything I have even if I feel like
I'm just going to pass out from
exhaustion so looking back now going
back to the 15 year old that came here
yeah did you envision any of this was
this something because we've talked to
so many people that said you know
somehow they knew they would get to this
point they didn't know mm-hmm I I always
it's hard to talk about Fame without you
know kind of sounding egotistical but I
did when I was a little girl you know I
was an only child and I didn't get a lot
of attention and I thought well I want
to be famous because I want to have a
lot of attention and I used to line up
my teddy bears and I would practice like
my academy award speech like if I ever
won so I knew it an early age that I
kind of wanted to be a star but that
changed so much for me because you know
I got here and I got to LA and I I did
that you know I did the thing where you
make a lot of money and you drive the
nice car and you go to the big meetings
and I wasn't happy it didn't fulfill me
and so my dreams that I had as
child changed from same to just wanting
to be an artist that would be able to do
what I love so that's what means so much
to me now
you